a very big week of news let's go to the
phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 and see what
is on people's minds starting with our
caller from the 707 area code caller
from 7:07 what's your name where are you
calling from today hello it's at me I'm
Bart Bart calling in from 707 yeah Bart
what's going on hey David thanks for
taking my call I had been spending
months trying to find out when the call
numbers were but it's and I realized it
finally it was that you had posted him a
fund on Twitter yes indeed so Mike my
first my first question was can you go
ahead and perhaps put them on the
website cause maybe a lot of people that
aren't on Twitter that may want to call
in Twitter Twitter works quite well
because sometimes the the time changes
and it's much easier to put a post up
but we'll certainly investigate that
sure appreciate that so I'm on Joe's
campaign now I joined up
so what recommended actions do you
recommend others like me you know for
the upcoming election in other words
what can we do from California
California where a blue state what can
we do from here now I've been on phone
banks and all that stuff you have any
specific recommendations you can give us
from states that are pretty safe in the
blue world for Joe to help in those
other states that may not be quite so
supportive well I I would be I'm
guessing that the the Biden campaign
understands this but I would be focusing
in on the stakes states likely to make a
difference there's a lot of good good
models online about which state is
likely to be the deciding stage and like
so for example my state of Massachusetts
almost no chance that it will be the
deciding state so it's not worth putting
a lot of time into phone banking here if
you look at a state like Michigan if you
look like Wisconsin other states way
more likely that they're going to be the
deciding factor so I mean I'm guessing
that the phone banking should
disproportionately be targeting those
states yes in that America
2018 I joined phone banks for various
people in Georgia and such I was trying
things like that but I didn't know if
you have specific groups that we should
you might call out for us to join or to
link up with
or whatever no I wouldn't have any I
certainly wouldn't have any group
recommendations but I would go by what
the what the Biden campaign is directing
the volunteers to do I wouldn't have
anything any special insight okay and
I'm learning to tell everybody you know
that maybe worried about Joe is that I'm
well I really wanted Bernie that to win
although I'm 60 but I'm still
progressive in my in my world of
thinking I think he's going to bring
along hopefully a very great vice
president candidate which maybe it's a
woman I hope so and that would allow the
whole system to be maybe give women a
better chance even to get to the
presidency in the future so I just
wanted to throw that out as if the pair
might be substantially better than even
Joe himself all right Bart very good
great to hear from you appreciate the
phone call and all very very well said